everyone the story of the Pentecost
a little bit about the community of the
believers and that one of their concerns
is not only to be together in prayer but
to be together in kind of generosity and
sharing and then with chapter 5 we move
to this odd story of Anna since Adonis
and Sapphira and the consequences of
sting genus any thoughts about how that
affects Luke's private project we won't
ask what it does for churches today
that's Jews from diba well it's thinking
about Luke and the way he handles the
the issues of wealth and poverty I think
he on the one side articulates a very
strong and perhaps authentic lay Jesus
sentiment that one should give up one's
earthly possessions and share them with
those who are in need so I think the the
image of the early Christian community
exercising a kind of Christian communism
as part of that ideal but even in the
gospel if you remember Luke tempers that
a little bit remember his encounter with
tsuchiya's tax collector oh absolutely
when he tells Zacchaeus to when Jesus
invites the key has to repent and Zakia
says yes fine I'll give back everything
I've stolen and and repay double and all
that good stuff I think that's kind of a
recognition that yeah there's a way in
which the church has to adapt to this
radical ideal you know so I think that
Luke's portrait of the early Christian
community is his gesture toward they the
call for this kind of radical dedication
or to find in the teachings of Jesus and
then the stories he tells as things go
on is a recognition of the way in which
the church actually came to understand
and live out those ideals and I think
they Ananias and Sapphira story is a nod
in the similar direction that we have
this this picture of an ideal early
Christian community and you might stop
and say gee whiz is that ever realized
in human experience and I think Luke
recognizes that it might be just a
little too ideal so he wants to show
with this this couple that was whole
some of their their funds from the the
common Kitty that yeah greed was there
even in there
a Christian community so I think it's a
gesture to agree the reality of human
nature I'm not sure it's a story that we
ought to be telling on stewardship
Sundays I remember when I was teaching
and the scripture at Notre Dame I used
to assign this as a course to preach on
for students they absolutely hated that
they couldn't find a good message yeah I
think someday we should do a book on
sermons you hate to preach and then give
suggestions on how you might get around
with this via great one is it also the
case that is as Luke begins to see and
this is a theme I think with him that
that Jesus is not gonna return soon the
church is going to be here that that
idea of sort of selling everything or
living communally maybe harder to
maintain over the long haul so over the
long haul you begin to think about
modified fallback positions on Christian
generosity yeah we certainly can trace
that kind of trajectory and early
Christian understanding general yeah and
down into the second century and you
have people like clement of alexandria
asking can a rich man be saved making
some sort of compromise between the
ideal and the reality of christian i
something like that is probably going on
at lok and this raises the issue of what
kind of eschatological horizon he's
operating within does he expect Jesus to
be coming back very very soon I don't
think so I don't think so either I think
the way in which he frames the the
predictions about the destruction of
Jerusalem of the gospel suggest that
he's pushing there at the end time out a
little bit and so there may be ways in
which his portrait of early Christianity
already adapts to that I think I think
the very fact that he writes acts means
that he knows that Jesus is not coming
tomorrow because otherwise you wouldn't
need this volume ten years later to talk
about next steps this is the kind of
book of next steps and when we get
further along I think some of the
questions about organization also become
questions of how the next steps go but
that becomes a nice segue for me into
the story of Stephen about which I have
a number of concerns I'd like you to
reflect on but one is you you have in
this in the story of Stephen and the
Apostles this distinction between the
Apostles and the Deacons
do you think that represents a kind of
movement right after Pentecost do you
think this is more reflective of the
life of the church that that Luke is
living say 20 years later 30 years later
you know I think the story of the
appointment of the first deacons in
Jerusalem combines what are probably
some historical reminiscences of the
development of the community in
Jerusalem with an organizational
structure that's important for later in
the first century the distinction that
is made between what the Apostles do
that is preach the gospel and what the
Deacons are supposed to do that is serve
a table yeah that we find at the
beginning of chapter 7 suggests that
yeah there were two different orders
here that have very different
responsibilities now what the Deacons
actually are reported to have done in
Luke suggests that those too much much
more yeah what will happen yeah but he
was elder like right exactly
and my my hunch is that the historical
reality is that the Deacons all of whom
have Greek name yeah represent a an
element of the early Christian community
in Jerusalem that's diaspora based yeah
they're coming from the Jews who come
from Greek speaking parts of of the
world and they have their synagogues and
their societies in Jerusalem where they
come on the pilgrimage festivals and the
like I think that's that's who they the
Deacons really were and they they
probably were not a subordinate rank of
clergy there later when we come to Paul
speech for instance to the Ephesian
elders yeah I think we get a hint of
that that's right I think we get a
reflection on what Lupe's the structure
of Luke's church is and that's being
imported I think and maybe something of
that is reflected in the pastoral
epistles 1st and 2nd Timothy and Titus
where it looks as if there's a different
order between elders or on the one hand
and deacons on the other Luke may be
hinting toward that already I think so
let's talk about Steven beyond that his
martyrdom what role does that play in
the story of let's talk about that for a
couple minutes then I'd like to hear
your reflections on his speech his long
sermon
yeah well Steven is there as is often
said said to be the first mod of a
profile model and his his death
imitates that of Jesus in many ways if
you think about some of the things that
are said about him at the end of chapter
7
he like Jesus says in 759 receive my
spirit yeah although he addresses this
to the Lord Jesus Jesus which is a nice
shift between gospel as early as the
echo of the gospel but Jefferson on
Jesus as being in a position of
authority and the echoes the the
sentiment of Jesus that is one of
compassion and forgiveness yeah at the
end of chapter 7 Lord do not hold this
sin against the same sort of thing that
Jesus is supposed to ask a real quick
question while we're on that one do you
think this indicates that the fact that
at times at the time that Luke and acts
are written we are having an ongoing
problem or ongoing opportunity for
Christian martyrdom and need that both
Jesus and Stephen in some ways become
prototypical martyrs for the martyrs of
Luke's on time mm-hmm well I think by
the time that Luke was written or that
Acts was real he's probably late for a
century and early 2nd century
there certainly had been Christian
martyrs yeah and there are stories of
persecution that that take place in the
late for a century under the mission I'm
not sure how widespread that persecution
was but certainly by the second decade
of the the 2nd century there are people
who are being martyred for the faith by
Romanov our it's like like plenty of the
elders who's a plenty of younger sorry
who's a Roman government within eeeh
so we know that that that sort of thing
was taking place there's probably some
reflection on on that reality and Luke's
account of Stephen and our readers our
heroes do they know that Peter and Paul
Abbott Margaret I think they were they
do will come to wrestle with this later
the story of Paul's death is not
recorded he only will have to make some
sense of that all right back to Stephens
bar bedroom so right so Stephen gets
modeled after giving this long speech
it's probably the longest speech in Acts
and I think it sounds some important
themes that good to keep in mind when
you're reading this whole book what is
the continuity with ancient Israel this
in effect is a story of salvation
history on the way in which God has
dealt with his chosen people over time
that's an important element but then
toward the end and we get this criticism
of the temple and that's a really
interesting motif isn't it because
early on in this I portrait the ideal
early community in Jerusalem the
Apostles and the women who we are I'm
including the mother of Jesus
break bread they have some sort of
Eucharistic celebration but they also go
and pray in the temporarily yeah yeah
yeah and the connection with the temple
is something that echoes the theme of
the gospel right the the gospel begins
zakaria around the temple yeah yeah and
Jesus goes to the temple Luke wants to
insist that this continuity out from the
general historical scheme and also in
institutional forms like the connection
with the temple but by the end of the
the story there seems to be more of a
break more of a gap between traditional
observant Jews and this new Jewish sect
of believers in Jesus and in some ways
the critique of the temple that you get
in Stephens speech is is a wedge that
begins to separate the two and so I
think it's part of their interesting
that that whole movement of criticism
and apology there Luke because I think
by the time of of Luke's writing this
work Christians by and large are
worshiping on their own in their
communities and not relating to the
temple and Luke writes at a time when
the temples gone right might would be my
guest so that both the gospel and the
and the book of Acts recognize the fact
that the temple has been destroyed in 70
by the Roman invaders you know it's
interesting that the move that Luke is
implicitly making here that you don't
need the temple for forgiveness and
reconciliation which is his major theme
and one of the things he thinks flows
from the death and resurrection of
Christ is analogous to a move that the
rabbi's make at the same time save so
say Morioka and ben zakai when they
asked about about sacrifice and temple
service said give arms and pray yeah
that's what that is temple yeah that's
right so there's a similar interesting
after the same problem right yeah in
interesting ways also a back to the
Deacons into Stephen under the
greek-speaking
we're beginning to get this edging
toward the larger and larger
manifestation of the gospel so you start
with Aramaic speaking people then all
kinds of people hear it now you've got
Greek speaking Jews who are clearly part
of the Ministry of the church as opposed
to the original Aramaic speaking 12
basically what do you do with this odd
story of the Ethiopian eunuch
yo P and you Philip and baptism but
maybe not quite baptism enough yeah yeah
so I think the first thing to notice the
the thing that you just sounded that is
that Luke was trying to tell the story
of the spread of the gospel and it's
going beyond the Jerusalem community
beyond the bounds of traditional Israel
going to the ends of the earth and one
end of the earth is Africa absolutely
and so this gives an entree to African
Christians and that the spread of the
gospel on that part of the world it also
was an entree to someone who would not
in many traditional senses be acceptable
as let's say a priest or exercise so
there's as if we find in Paul neither
male nor female slave nor free Jew nor
Greek that this loop here to was saying
everybody is welcome in this community
even Ethiopian eunuch say yeah now
another thing it happens is I think the
the little speech that Philip gives when
he's talking to the eunuch and
convincing him that he ought to become a
a Christian what he does is to cite
scripture absolutely any cites one of
the Isaiah servant songs it's one of the
few texts in the New Testament that does
so explicitly does that we often think
of these that these isaiah in texas
relevant to understanding the death of
christ it's it's striking how
infrequently they're used a new test
very but here it is like a sheep he was
led to the slaughter like a lamb silent
before it's Shearer's so he Jesus was
not open his mouth etc so this is in
acts 8:32 so I think this is one of
these many places where in the early
chapters of Acts in particular Lucas is
putting on the table some of the
scriptural text that he has found
particularly significant for
understanding of Jesus's yeah yeah
absolutely yeah and there's a kind of
model for preaching you have the things
that I love the most which is pay
attention to the context and have a text
and Philip has both presided by the
eunuch mm-hmm
and on the baptism issue Luke seems to
have a couple of different models in
mind and he hasn't really brought them
together into a coherent whole the the
model that emerges later you get
baptized in water and the Holy Spirit
comes upon you as a result of that
perhaps through anointing yeah that's
one model right it comes to dominate
early Christian baptismal practice that
ain't necessarily so I know in Luke the
spirit can come on its own
yeah again God can be in charge yeah
exactly now but baptism is somehow an
important part of the whole process
whether or not the spirit comes there's
a little bit of that cleanup squad that
if you only had the baptism of John
which is the repentance thing you
haven't got the spirit side of it yet so
we need to add that so the spirit is
important find for the spirit is
crucially important in some ways I think
the book of Acts is the history of the
Spirit as much as it's the history of
the church say a couple words in closing
this session about Paul standing by when
Stephen gets murdered what are we doing
there okay so at the model room of
Stephen we have the introduction of the
figure of Paul for the first time and
ironically he who will be persecuted is
now among the persecutors this picks up
a theme and Paul something that he
himself would say so I think Luke knows
a certain amount about Paul whether he
knows all his his letters he knows some
of the themes of Paul's preaching so we
have that that introduced and yeah we're
going to hear a lot more about this
figure as time goes on and it's I think
Luke's a smart narrator he's a finest
remedies also pretty good novelist we
use you get our man in who's gonna
become the star of the last two thirds
of this book and you get him in in a
role it's gonna be important he's a
persecutor of the church mm-hmm he's but
it's a bit of a tease it's an excellent
tease right terrific thank you very much